the impeachment trial as I mentioned is
in its third day yeah and here's a clip
from this afternoon session
we plan to take short breaks every two
or three hours and will accommodate a
30-minute recess for dinner assuming
that is negative it's like watching a
candle melt I it's unbelievable I have
to I hate to say it I know it's an
important part of our democratic system
it is really dull and turns out not many
people are watching these hearings in
fact these hearings have been so boring
I'm going to show you some of the
programming on other networks that has
easily beaten the impeachment trial in
the ratings this is how bad it is
ESPN beats me impeachment trial they
completely beat the impeachment trial
with stadium waves that never really get
going
this was the programming they put on
[Applause]
that destroy destroy yeah there's
another one
national they're so boring National
Geographic beat the impeachment trial
with a special called predators and prey
leaving each other alone impeachment is
so boring
HBO Ethiopian hearings with footage of a
hatless george RR martin set to banjo
music
[Music]
I push ya
I pushed it rehearsal to cut that one
overruled
[Applause]
so boring I tell you these impeachment
hearings they're so boring turner
classic movies beat them with just the
subtitles check it out
[Music]
short boring Telemundo beat them with a
special called people who don't speak
Spanish
[Music]
and finally finally Pietschmann hearings
are so boring espn2 beat them with
competitive dog dream races
[Applause]
and he not got him right